طريق سريع مزدحم عادة في
مدينة ووهان الصين شبه فارغ ،
فقط عدد قليل من المركبات المارة
أغلقت وسائل النقل العام حافلات المدينة
دون أن يمسها سوى عدد قليل من السكان الذين شوهدوا في
الخارج لمدينة 11 مليون
شخص يطلق عليهم سلاسل الطعام الرئيسية في المنزل
إغلاق للعملاء من ستاربكس  إلى
كنتاكي فرايد تشيكن إلى ماكدونالدز مطفأة داخل
وول مارت المفتوح والمتسوقون المزدحمون الذين
يرتدون أقنعة الوجه في الداخل
وشراء ما تبقى من
المنتجات العارية يقف خلف
منطقة الإغلاق المشاهد المماثلة عبر
البر الرئيسي للصين ، هناك 24 مليون شخص
في شنغهاي وأنا أسير في
وصلت جينا ديفيدسون ، وهي طالبة جامعية أمريكية في منتصف الشارع ، إلى شنغهاي قبل بضعة أسابيع
في فصل الربيع كما تعلم أننا وصلنا إلى هنا
قبل اندلاع المرض ، يبدو الأمر سريعًا حقًا
، وتقول إن العثور على الطعام في المدينة الضخمة
أصبح صعبًا بشكل متزايد في
حرمنا الجامعي الذي شعرنا به تقريبًا.  على الرغم من أنهم
لم يدركوا أننا ما زلنا
نعيش عليه لأنه لم يكن لدينا مثل هذا
الجو الحار  المياه لبضعة أيام
والكافيتريات في الحرم الجامعي مغلقة لذلك
بدأنا ندرك جيدًا أننا بحاجة إلى الطعام
وتم إغلاق معظم المتاجر التي تقع على مسافة قريبة أو مثل
Zombieland التي تقاتل من أجل ما تبقى
على الرفوف حاولت جينا في البداية
الحفاظ على الإيجابية  هذا هو الرجل الذي يقيس
درجة حراري تسع مرات في اليوم ، حتى أنها
أرسلت هذه الصورة إلى والدها في محاولة
لطمأنته أنها وزملاؤها في
الفصل حجزوا الآن رحلات جوية
للخروج من الوجهة في أي مكان ولكن هنا إلى
أين أنت ذاهب إلى أفريقيا من
تعرف في  أفريقيا لا أعرف أي شخص في
إفريقيا والأمر الأكثر إرهاقًا هو أنني
لم أكن أعرف أننا نغادر ، ما زلت لا
أشعر أننا سنكون واضحين حتى الآن لأن
هذا أعني ماذا لو استقلناها في
سيارة الأجرة
أو في  المطار في طريق العودة إلى المنزل على
متن الطائرة ، ما زلنا بحاجة إلى توخي الحذر الشديد
لأنه لم ينته بعد. تظهر
[الموسيقى]
مرة أخرى في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي whoo كيف
يواصل بعض السكان التحرك داخل منازلهم
ليجدوا الحياة الطبيعية داخل الإغلاق ولكن
إلقاء نظرة على  utside وتذكيرك بأن الحياة
هنا ليست شيئًا عاديًا سوى
David Culver CNN Beijing
[موسيقى]
الزيادة المستمرة في الحالات والأدلة على
وجود فريق بشري ونقل
خارج الصين كانت بالطبع
مقلقة للغاية على الرغم من أن الأرقام خارج
الصين لا تزال  صغير نسبيًا
لديهم إمكانية تفشي أكبر بكثير
، لذا قررت
إعادة عقد
لجنة الطوارئ للوائح الصحية الدولية بشأن
فيروس كورونا الجديد 2019 لإسداء النصح لي بشأن ما إذا
كان تفشي المرض يمثل حالة طوارئ صحية عامة
تثير قلقًا دوليًا
وللسعي للحصول على توصياتهم حول
أفضل السبل  لحماية الناس في جميع أنحاء
العالم.
أدوات التحديات بالامتنان - كانت الاستجابة
هائلة و  تستحق الحكومة الصينية
تقديراً كبيراً لهذا الرد
والشفافية التي
تعاملت من خلالها مع هذا الأمر